I've just had an apostrophe.
I think you mean an "epiphany".
How do you feel about apostrophes?
A mountain naming committee in Thurman, New York recently learned...
...that there's been a silent war of sorts being waged against the apostrophe.
The specific name they wanted was being debated,...
...but all of the top suggestions ended with apostrophe s,...
...as the peak was being named to honor the local 1700s settler James Cameron.
Apparently, that kind of punctuation use...
...doesn't fly with The Domestic Names Committee of the US Board on Geographic Names.
According to the agency,...
...naming public places with an apostrophe s at the end implies too much individual possession,...
...rather than giving an air of belonging to all of the people.
In the 113-year history of the organization,...
...a handful of possessive apostrophe attempts have made it through.
Their most steadfast adherence to their rule doesn't mean that people approve of it.
In 2009, the group was criticized at a meeting for its "isolationist stance".
The British have encountered similar troubles,...
...but in 2001, the Apostrophe Protection Society was founded in England...
...to fight for the apostrophe's rights.